[Music]
I've noticed you're pretending to
masturbate and I was wondering if you
wanted to talk about it wish my mom was
a sex guru sir why don't you start by
telling me your earliest memory of your
scrotum trust me you don't know this is
a new frontier my sexually repressed
friend our chance to finally move up the
social food chain
I'm worried about you man everybody's
either thinking about cycling about too
shy or actually shaggy
the students that the school needs your
help and we need their money I'll deal
with the business and things and you can
do therapy serve their sex therapy about
your mom Wow six therapists this could
be awesome we could be popular and I
have a mild to moderate crush on lave
I'm addicted to wanking my pubes are out
control I wish I could be a normal kid
with and all that with a normal dick
therefore the best two years of our
lives
let me get you some condoms oh thanks
mom
stay out my life Mandy not to be what
kind of Matt you want me to be that
can't you is who you're attracted to
come engineer a relationship I don't
believe in huh you are who you are
doesn't anyone take that away from you
I still think it's a way to teenage boys
a sex therapist
[Music]